[Music]
for years I wanted has been at peace but
something is coming I can feel dark
forces are upon us
find these beasts or whatever they are
our world is dying there is nothing to
go back to if our people are to survive
we must make a whole media
whatever happens what happens if we do
not unite our world will perish this
doesn't need to happen there is one who
may help us
for dorks there is militant life at war
no but with the humans help there could
be
lying here to save all people can we
trust him
the beasts they should all be destroyed
are you sure of that
we'll protect the king you and I
inside with a human
against your own kind
is the suicide we have no choice we
should attack with full force whatever
you plan to do do it
it has begun war is coming if we do not
unite our world will perish
like when I hit a good man well then I
better get going
we'll protect the kingdom with this
Warcraft rated pg-13 dark forces are
upon us
o world is on the magic walk its death
to all things so are you here to save
our people for orcs there was no other
life but war but with the humans help
there could be
can we trust him
their beasts they should all be
destroyed they serve out there how can
we start with the humans but it's the
only kind is the suicide
we'll protect a kingdom you and I we
will try boyfriend
Warcraft the beginning
we've had peace in these lands for many
years now but one of our villages burned
tonight war is coming
an invasion
if we do not unite to fight this enemy
our world will perish saving the world
is not a one-man job we fight together
or we die together we'll have made a
protect you I need no one to protect me
Elvan
[Music]
they're stronger be smarter
this war will destroy us all
but together we might stand a chance
whatever you plan to do do it now
it has begun war is coming so are you
here to save all people we must fight
together can we trust him
that beasts they should all be destroyed
are you sure about that
we'll protect the kingdom you and I we
will try what friend Warcraft rated
pg-13
dark forces are upon us find the